a few pastors have defied government
orders to stop holding gatherings of
more than 10 people but most places of
worship were happy to say are following
the rules CBS News special correspondent
James Brown spoke with two prominent
preachers about spreading the gospel
during this pandemic so this is our
congregation today for 40 years Reverend
Calvin butts has preached in front of
thousands at the historic Abyssinian
Baptist Church but for the past three
weeks preaching has been a solitary
affair at this landmark sanctuary in
Harlem New York we decided to do virtual
services after we heard the projections
for the number of cases that rx were
expected at that time and now we see
that it's become a reality and we were
convinced that the health and safety of
our congregants comes first as a speaker
how is impacting you in your virtual
presentations well it's a little
difficult you know I'm from that call
and response tradition we want to hear
somebody say Amen or say talk or
something even when I look out into an
empty sanctuary if the Spirit comes then
I can present the Word of God pastor
Craig Altman of Grace Family Church in
Tampa Florida has also taken to the
Internet to stay connected with his
11,000 member congregation he too admits
that he had to make an adjustment be
honest it's very difficult when you're
standing in an empty room of no one
there you don't have the energy you
would like what was the decision-making
process to decide to go virtual versus
having in-person services and we
realized love is really protecting
people and protecting the vulnerable and
that really drove our decision to say
you know we want to do our best not to
injure our community in any way pastors
butts and Altman stand in contrast to
some preachers who continue to hold
in-person church services Florida pastor
rodney howard-browne was arrested for
violating health emergency orders and
yesterday louisiana pastor tony spell
held palm sunday services despite being
charged with six misdemeanors last week
of course we want to believe that God
can protect
this but I think there's a balance
between due diligence and concern
Reverend buck says at first even he had
to be convinced I would say you can't
stop us from worshiping but someone had
to really sit down and say look Calvin
but this is a serious matter good
religion goes best with some common
sense
pastor Altman says moving to online
services during the corona virus
pandemic may prove to be a blessing in
disguise
now with the strictly online service
were hitting 45,000 households every
weekend so we've sent a big expansion of
growths 45,000 online viewers pastor
Craig yes it's it's pretty amazing and
as these two prominent preachers begin
the most important week on the Christian
calendar both have a message of hope I
know that God will provide that our
people will get on the internet they are
tuned into virtual services and even
those who can't get to their churches
will tune into us we're gonna see a
resurrection of our economy of people's
lives and I know that God's gonna get us
through this well and I can't wait for
that James Brown joins us now from his
home in Maryland hey James in a news
conference on Saturday President Trump
mentioned that he's thinking about maybe
allowing churches to meet in person on
Easter and listen I think people need
church they want church at this time but
that seems to be a bit confusing even
though we all love a good call in
response what are your thoughts on that
well I'm sure you know as well that
leadership is best delivered when
they're in unison there's a coherent
message as opposed to one that could be
confusing
I think the pastors we interviewed show
they're trying to find that best balance
and I think pastor bud said it best that
religion is best served with common
sense common sense never gets old
thank you very much James